there is no justice and there is no
combating climate change without
addressing what has happened to
indigenous communities that means that
there is no fixing our economy without
addressing the racial wealth gap that
means that we are not going to
transition to renewable energies without
also transitioning frontline communities
and coal communities into economic
opportunity as well that is what this is
about it is comprehensive it is
thoughtful it is compassionate and is
extremely economically strategic as well
today is also the day that we choose to
assert ourselves as a global leader in
transitioning to a hundred percent
renewable energy and charting that path
that means that we are not going to peg
ourselves by the lowest Veit by the
lowest standards of other nations it
doesn't mean that we're going to say
what about them they're not doing it
what about them they're not doing it why
should we we should do it because we
should lead we should do it because that
is what this nation is about we should
do it because we are a country founded
on ideals of a culture that is
innovative that that cares for our
brothers and sisters across this country
we should do it because we are an
example to the world that is why we
should do it